[Musique]
je suis adhérent du modem depuis 2015
mais en vérité mon histoire est ce que
modem remonter un petit peu plus tôt en
2007 à l'époque je suis lycéen en
terminale je suis de fin d'année où j'ai
17 ans et demi tout ma classe vote sauf
moi je suis une grande attention le
débat des présidentielles j'observe une
polarisation du débat et surtout
beaucoup d'eux de mauvaise foi dans le
jeu politique où à droite caricature la
gauche et la gauche pareil et je vois
émerger un personnage s'appelle françois
bayrou ok je m'intéresse déjà est
frustré de pas pouvoir voter je fais une
petite campagne à mon niveau puisque
j'arrive à convaincre mes deux parents
de voter pour fois sans dire où je me
suis retrouvé au modem je venais de
prendre ma carte adhérent et g
c'était un petit peu nerveux j'avais 18
ans et je me souviens que j'avais croisé
mâle de sarnez et j'avais écouté le
problème c'est que je connais personne
ici à part vous et vous connaissez pas
dans qu'est ce que je fais et elle m'a
dit allez viens avec moi et m'a
accompagné et m'a présenté à tout le
monde m'a fait me sentir bien et ensuite
je me suis aperçu que c'est un groupe
qui était fabuleux entouré de d'esprits
brillants de gens qui partagent les
mêmes valeurs que moi et du coup c'était
plaisant le modem c'est une pensée qui
remontent du coup qu'ils puissent ses
racines dans une encre en politique est
comme à ses anciens on a tendance à
l'oublier c'est pas juste un courant qui
se trouve au milieu entre la droite et
la gauche il ya une vraie histoire une
vraie pensée j'ai découvert des gens
extrêmement intéressant des valeurs qui
ne correspondent totalement notamment
concernant l'europe et l'humanisme et du
coup je suis resté et je compte bien
rester parce qu'il va convaincu
d'adhérer au modem c'est que j'ai
rencontré des personnes qui étaient
particulièrement démocrate
qui était également cartésienne et
humaniste j'ai trouvé une famille qui
avait exactement le maître le mode de
pensée que je recherchais alors moi j'ai
adhéré donc au modem parce que si des
valeurs qui me plaisent et puis ça fait
longtemps que
je m'interroge sur mes convictions
politiques et donc c'était vraiment un
moyen pour moi de voir m'engager et
étant donné que ça me correspond c'est
d'autant plus intéressant je me suis
engagé au modem parce que je me retrouve
dans les valeurs que ce parti défend les
valeurs de pragmatisme de progressisme
de liberté et de dépassement
d'engagement alors tout d'abord j'ai
envie de dire qu'il est très important
de s'engager donné qu'il est question de
notre destin finalement pourquoi le mot
dit amr tout d'abord parce que le moden
ça ça permet justement d'avoir une
approche assez éclectique des choses
pourraient toucher à plusieurs domaines
différents développez votre réflexion
c'est ce qu'il ya de plus important et
les avantages du modem ce que nous ne
sommes pas dans un parti
entre 10 mai avec une pensée unique au
contraire ici il sera question de
développer votre réflexion personnelle
c'est donc à mon sens le plus grand
intérêt du modem au modem on est libre
on est libre donc c'est déjà très c'est
très intéressant pour un adhérent parce
qu'on aime le débat on est profondément
attaché à la discussion est justement à
ce débat démocratique
on est là pour donner envie de découper
les politiques et de croire en les
politiques puisque perse plus personne
ne croit en rien en tout cas beaucoup
beaucoup de personnes ne croient plus en
la représentativité
des élus notamment ils ne se
reconnaissent plus on est là donc déjà
pour faire ce travail
de retour à
l'expérience démocratique
[Musique]